what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time i'm here with
polina
marinova pompliano we are at an
undisclosed location
we're in the cia okay i was just going
to comment on your
lack of athleticism even though you have
athletic wear on
but don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by blockfy
blackfy has three products you can buy
and sell crypto you can deposit crypto
and take out a us dollar loan
as a against your crypto collateral i
almost messed that up that would be
really bad
or you can use my favorite product as an
investor and i said on the board
which is an interest-bearing account
where you can earn up to eight point six
percent apy
in that interest bearing account go
check it out block five dot com slash
pomp go
do it block five dot com slash pomp go
do it
what's up hey guys this light is just
doing me
favors today okay i like making him feel
uncomfortable
um square the fintech mobile
payments app company has revealed
that it deployed 50 million dollars of
capital
on its balance sheet to purchase
bitcoin jack dorsey is doubling and
tripling down
as the end of the second quarter of 2020
50 million represents around
one percent of squares total
assets i love this move why
because every company's gonna do this
the dollar just continues to lose value
in a zero
interest rate environment how do people
get any money
how do they protect their wealth they
can't individuals can't and corporations
can't so what do they do
they turn to the greatest soundest
hardest money
ever greatest which is bitcoin can i
read you what the cfo said of square
sure squares chief financial officer
said we believe that bitcoin has the
potential to be a more ubiquitous
currency in the future
as it grows in adoption we intend to
learn and participate in a disciplined
way
for a company that is building products
based on a more inclusive future
this investment is a step on that
journey so basically they're putting
skin in the game
if they're in it they'll learn about it
they'll participate in it they'll help
it grow
i love how expertly
they're navigating the waters here
because they just put bitcoin on their
balance sheet
the equivalent of what they just said in
that press release on crypto
twitter bitcoin twitter is yolo market
buy
because that's literally this move is
enormous enormous and what it does is
michael saylor from microstrategy was
the first to do it
um on a public company side uh he put
85 percent of his balance she's not one
percent 85 425 million of his 500
million dollars
now jack and square are doing it uh my
favorite part of the whole thing though
is that they open sourced the
information
uh of how they did it at the bottom of
the press release
and therefore anybody else who wants to
do it now has the playbook
that's awesome okay hot take but i
really like track
that's not a hot take i feel like a lot
of people don't i think people are
stupid that's fine whatever
just because people are dumb oh that's
mine
sorry just because people are dumb
doesn't mean uh
that uh jack's like a bad dude and by
the way he runs two multi-billion dollar
companies and guess what's in his
twitter bio
one word bitcoin oh really
facts what yeah did not know that okay
he's a believer
citigroup on the other hand let's talk
about legacy financial
finance citigroup has agreed to pay a
400 million
penalty for failing to address several
long-standing deficiencies across the
company u.s banking regulators said
the federal reserve and office of the
controller of the currency said in
separate statements that the bank must
overhaul its risk management
data government governance and internal
controls across the company
noting that it needs comprehensive
corrective actions
so while these banking institutions are
having issues with data and governance
of privacy
bitcoin is not well right
i would make a connection between these
organizations and bitcoin i would just
say that like look
there's more money laundering and
nefarious activity that goes on on wall
street
than anywhere else and they're just
getting caught and by the way
citigroup doesn't care about this they
literally just budget into their
annual expenses or we're going to pay
some fines
just part it's literally just the cost
of doing business 400 million dollars
cost of doing business for them i'm done
complaining about it there's nothing i
can do about it it is what it is
next okay a company that was started as
a joke
now raised 31 million dollars
pre-launch although i'm in their beta i
have yet to try it out but i'm really
excited about it
it's called
it's really hard to say but it's the
company
um basically what it allows you to do is
customize
your presentation screen on zoom or
whatever you use
by like making slides bigger by pointing
to specific sentences by
being able to make yourself smaller or
bigger it's really cool you should look
at the demo it's called
mmhm they can see it in the rundown
but basically yeah it was started in may
as kind of a joke during shelter in
place
but now has thousands of test users a
weightless of 100 000 people
and as of wednesday a fresh 31 million
in funding to expand
it's a really well made product based on
what i've seen and i've seen people use
it
and i'm like that's freaking cool it's
pretty crazy
phil libben uh who is the founder of
this
uh he created evernote so
he knows what he's doing yeah it's a
weekend update
style screen appears on the right side
of the virtual room and you can just
maybe we should do lunch money with
mm-hmm
what's next okay this is a company
that is europe's answer to twilio it's
called message bird i first wrote about
it when they raised their series a
funding
now they're raising 200 million dollars
in a mega round of funding that values
the company at 3 billion
it's based in amsterdam it's a cloud
communications firm
and um yeah it's experienced the surge
in demand during the covet pandemic it
sells software that makes it easier for
companies to communicate with their
customers
through a range of channels including
sms voice and messaging platforms
such as whatsapp the reason it's
encouraging this company
to a lot of other startups and
entrepreneurs is because it's based in
europe
but it's gotten a ton of silicon valley
interest
i know nothing about this company oh
yeah it's cool 200 million is a lot of
money three billion dollar evaluation is
really big
they claim to have over 15 000 clients
globally including sap uber etc
so when uber sends a message they power
the thing but twilio is
way bigger right but twilio is also the
establishment at this point
i remember using twilio uh back in like
2015 and literally it was like
is it gonna get delivered now to see
that it's just a massive company is
awesome they did a great job yeah okay
so are you looking for a joke no
there is a chicken chicken industry
probe that's a very big
crimes in the chicken industry crimes in
the second six additional executives of
chicken producers were indicted by a
federal grand jury in denver for
conspiring to fix
prices the charges are the latest in the
justice department's ongoing
investigation to price fixing in the
industry
four executives were charged in june for
their role so
there's 10 executives who conspired to
fix prices
and rig bids for broiler chicken
products
is that absurd so it's pilgrim's pride
there's one a georgia-based company
called claxton poultry farms
not great guys not great this is pretty
crazy
how um there's price fixing in the
chicken industry
and there's executives named william
cantola
fine name and jimmy little and all i
keep thinking about is
chicken little thank you for the
commentary
i'm just saying that's fine okay that's
all i have to say it's just chicken
little
that's it i don't know anything about
the price fixing in the chicken industry
we just woke up guys i think this is uh
yeah fine i don't know anything about uh
chicken uh chicken fries but i do know
that they're being charged with things
that could carry a maximum fine of 10
years in prison
yeah they're trying to fix chicken
prices no
yeah maybe okay allegedly are you ready
for my favorite story of the day
story story
tesla owner says he butt dialed a 4280
autopilot upgrade to
tesla and he's still waiting on his
refund
what dr ali vaziri says he was charged
for a forty four thousand two hundred
eighty
soft dollar software upgrade for his
test on september 24th
without even being aware of opening the
app and has been trouble
has had trouble getting the refund it's
so
easy you can but dial a refund on your
uh
and uh uh what is that an auto update on
your tesla it's that easy
yeah that's pretty crazy right yeah i
mean
it's not really tesla's fault like they
made it too easy
if i could dial in auto pilot update
come on
it's like saying uh like put a lock on
your phone dude so it doesn't butt dial
well sometimes yeah but like well i have
no experience of sitting on my phone and
my jeans but
that's a different problem okay
what's next what did the drummer call
his twin daughters
what a joke what did the drummer call
his twin daughters
[Laughter]
oh no but that's close like drum drum
no okay so the drummer called his twin
daughters
and a one and a two
i apologize for putting you through this
every day
that's it for lunch money today we will
talk to you guys tomorrow don't like it
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends